the fourth of July means fireworks plugs
and food but before you fire up the
grill ever wonder what's really in the
hotdogs you're eating hot dogs can be
made of any combination of pork veal or
poultry it starts with the trimmings
that means bits of muscle bone fat
animal heads feet blood and organ meats
can all go into the mix the meat is
ground into tiny particles or
mechanically separated from there it's
mixed with spices and binders which can
include corn syrup dried milk and grains
oh and a dash of preservatives to keep
your hotdogs fresh then hot dogs are
stuffed into a casing for shapes before
curing the casing may be removed before
sale or left on but natural casing means
one thing intestine still hungry